it's very important that people
understand that as a result of the cuts
made by
other countries last year four million
people
are now said to be facing famine in
yemen
that's in total population of 24 million
18 million people dependent on
humanitarian aid
for survival today the announcement has
been made by
a number of countries about their plans
for the next year
and it looks like the un is about two
billion pounds
short of what's needed they asked for
about 3.9 billion pounds
they're only getting about i think 1.7
billion and my understanding is that the
secretary general of the un has
described this as a death sentence
so it couldn't be more serious and
britain has for a long time been a
leader of humanitarian efforts as your
numbers
indicate but it's honestly inexplicable
that this is the occasion to cut by half
the amount of british aid for the
world's worst humanitarian crisis
just one final point by way of
introduction this isn't just about
humanitarian policy britain on the un
security council
is in charge of the yemen file and
obviously
that puts it in pole responsibility for
diplomatic
efforts to resolve the crisis which now
have a fighting chance
given the arrival of the biden
administration this determination to
have
a different way forward so from a
british national interest a british
reputation
point of view as well as from the point
of view of yemenis
who are desperately needing
international help this is a very sad
day
well just on that reputational point of
view then
from the uk does it and as you mentioned
there with the
boris johnson chairing you and security
council meetings
does it weaken the uk's moral authority
well that's the great fear i think
because britain has had
a very good record over the last 20
years or so
on the global development and
humanitarian
scene and the cuts in the aid budget
are going to impact some of the poorest
people in the world because british aid
is efficiently delivered
effectively delivered reaching the front
line as it happens the uk has appointed
you showing the pictures i can see and
they're
they're they're the most heart-rending
pictures britain has actually made a
priority
under the johnson government of fighting
famine it's got a famine
envoy well here's one of the world's
four famine
crises that are on the international
scene
at the moment and the idea that it's the
moment to cut aid in half as i say
it's not just me who's saying it's
inexplicable i gather jeremy hunt who
was a
successor of mine at the foreign office
he's also called it inexplicable and i
think inexcusable
as well andrew mitchell conservative mp
former
development secretary this is where the
rubber is hitting the road and so
britain's reputation
depends on our actions and our words
being in sync
is it inexcusable though given that
other countries
are also cutting and
19 even in hugely rich countries like
the united kingdom
is just devouring financial resources
well my understanding is that germany
for example has actually
increased its aid to yemen today i think
to 200 million euros that they're
spending
i haven't got the us figure yet but
judging by the comments of secretary
tony blink and i think the u.s is
increasing
its aid to yemen everyone understands
that governments have their first
responsibility on the home front but the
international aid
to yemen is an absolute fragment a
fraction
of the extra borrowing that the
chancellor has rightly undertaken to
save the british economy
and when it comes to famine abroad
britain the british people
have always been determined to save
human life first and that's what we're
talking about here
and just in terms of the the overall
situation in yemen in particular the war
there you mentioned
the new biden administration the new
secretary of state with a very
different approach towards saudi arabia
towards the united arab emirates
do you see perhaps a potential solution
longer term coming from that route
pressure by the us
on those participants in the war
yes is the short answer to that the u.s
has announced an end to
support for offensive operations by the
saudi-led coalition of which it's apart
it's also ended the attempted
designation
of the houthi rebel movement as a global
terrorist force they control 80
of the country and so you need to engage
with them
but now we need three more things that
we've discussed on your program
over the years first a proper ceasefire
so that the humanitarian aid can get
going
secondly a proper accountability for the
crimes that have been committed on all
sides
thirdly an effective peace process and
there is a
u.n negotiating he's british as it
happens martin griffiths he needs to be
able to get on with his job
because at the moment the country is not
just a facing famine it's falling apart
and that is a political disaster in the
making